Speaker 1: And speaking of bullies. How
about we go over to Lauren Boebert right now?
Lauren Boebert this week sent a letter to
Transportation Secretary Pete booted edge,
begging him for $33 million to construct a new
bridge in her district, a new bridge that she
says is going to help with evacuations. It's going
to help with emergency vehicles because, you know,
Colorado has a lot of wildfires. And Boebert
says, look, we get you got this money from the
infrastructure bill. We would love for you to,
you know, come and spend this $33 million on a
new bridge. People need it. People could die
without it, honestly. All good points, right?
But the irony here, of course, is that Lauren
Boebert has spent the last year mocking.
Pete Moody judges sexuality. Yeah. When he
took paternity leave. She went on national
media and said he's probably learning how
to chest feed. You've mocked his husband.
You've mocked everything about this man. You have
blamed him for things that are not even his fault.
And now you have the audacity. To look up to him
and say, hey, how about 33 million over here for
a new bridge for my district? So I don't, you
know, get creamed in my election. I kind of
need to do something for these people because
I've done nothing. So would you help me out?
Now. I will say she should not be punished just
because she is a horrible person. Now rephrase
that her constituents should not be punished just
because they sent a horrible person to Congress.
They have the opportunity to right that wrong.
Actually, I think it's coming up next week. Right.
They got that primary. Don Corum, the Republican
running against her. You've got Democrats
that have switched from being Democrats to
registered either independents or Republicans
so they can go vote against
Lauren Boebert in that primary.
Like there is this massive, concerted
effort to get this individual out of office.
And it's because she's a horrible person.
And for the Republicans. In her district.
It's because she's completely ineffective.
That's why she's sending this last minute
pitch to boot a judge. Yeah. That's why she's
pretending that she hasn't spent the last year
basically calling him a horrible person
because he's not a straight white man.
She needs that $33 million bridge to
be able to show her constituents, yes,
I may do crazy things sometimes, but hey,
look, I delivered for you. And unfortunately,
they do need the bridge. And I personally
do not believe. In abusing political power.
You know, just to make an individual pay,
you know, just to punish a political rival.
That's not okay. You know, just
ask Chris Christie in Bridgegate,
something everybody forgot about a scandal that
honestly today probably wouldn't even be a scandal
considering the scandals we see these days.
But again, it's the same thing with Marjorie
Taylor. GREENE You can't spend your whole life
just being a horrible person to everybody you
come in contact with and then expect them to be
nice to you. I mean, this is basic, you know,
growing up type stuff, your mother's,
your father. Is anybody any kind of,
you know, adult figure in your life should have
taught you this when you were young children.
You get back what you put in. I know my mother
told me that a million times. She'll still tell
me that to this day. And that's not saying
that you have to sit there and suffer the
slings and arrows of everyone coming after you.
You can stand up for yourself. Absolutely. But
there's a difference between standing up
for yourself and being an outright bully,
which is what people like Lauren Boebert
and Marjorie Taylor GREENE have become